[Music]  you guys have said that you've it's hard  not to think about Monty Python when  you're making this show sometimes feels  like you're always 10 degrees away from  from Monty Python right yes you could  turn to seen this much and it's a great  Monty Python scene I think as a huge  Monty Python fan it's something that  that I need to be careful of because the  temptation it's like you're at the wheel  and it's you you know it's kind of you  want to do it because it would be so  much fun if you did it for that moment  but it would ruin the show now Dan and  David you guys do you know how this this  whole story ends yes sir you do all  right let's have it  but you can't tweet this yeah very few  people will find out  you